I have an atelier ramen rife machine. Should I add the foot bath apparatus? No, I don't recommend
that because the atelier ramen rife machine allows you to do the higher frequencies that royal rife
actually used for cancer patients with the bulb where the true rife doesn't. You can only get up to
about 10 to 12,000 hurts with the royal rife where you can get up to 30,000 with the atelier
ramen. So you really don't need the foot bath where the iron pro-wave for the true rife came in
is that you could do those higher frequencies with the iron pro-wave that you couldn't do with the
bulb with the plasma bulb with the atelier ramen. You don't need that because you could do those
higher frequencies with the bulb which I think is superior. So anything you can do with light,
I think it's much better than doing with the foot bath anyhow. So we don't recommend, I personally
don't recommend the foot bath apparatus. We have some people that have it and they're just like,
I just want to do a foot bath but it's not something that the reason why we recommend the foot bath
with the true rife is to get those higher frequencies. Well, that's a no point with the atelier